a warning this report contains details
of violent sexual assault
sophie is still haunted by what happened
to her when she was just 12 years old
her horrific ordeal might have been
prevented but those who were supposed to
protect her didn't back in 2006 sophie
was out with her friends when a man
assaulted her i went to the police
station to ask for help
the officers didn't help me at all
they just told me to go home
there was two men at the door that
offered to take me and the officers were
fine about it and i was just took
the men took sophie from the station and
sexually assaulted her in a car and it
only got worse she then ended up in two
different houses
over 24 hours eight men attacked her she
was raped multiple times
it's unimaginable
to think that could even happen
but it does
but now all you can do is protect others
and stop it from continuing
this man shaquille chowdry is the only
person to have been jailed for abusing
sophie that night and she's angry
if you can't go to your authorities then
who can you go to
what happened to sophie has been looked
at by an independent review into
allegations of child sexual exploitation
in oldham we have been given a
provisional copy of part of that review
before it's published it details how
sophie was badly let down by the police
and social services
the document says there were significant
opportunities missed by children's
social care to intervene and put in
place appropriate arrangements to
protect sophie the review goes on to
state no one raised concerns about the
apparent failure to protect sophie when
she presented herself at the police
station we believe this is evidence of a
significant failing by greater
manchester police in their treatment of
a vulnerable 12 year old child
and by denying they'd fallen short of
their duties to sophie the review says
both agencies created the impression of
a cover-up the police will apologize to
her and sky news understands the council
will too
how difficult is it to rebuild that
trust an apology means nothing now you
know they've been found at fault but
it's too late
damage is already done
the people in charge need to go that's
the only way it can be rebuilt and trust
can happen
greater manchester police said it's not
appropriate for them to comment in
detail until the review is published but
said this woman has tragically
experienced lasting harm as a result of
what happened to her and our failure to
protect her we fully intend to express
our deepest and most sincere apology
directly to her
the date for publishing the oldham
review has been repeatedly pushed back
it's also looked at other historical
allegations of child abuse sophie has
already waited years for answers now she
wants action becky cottrell sky news